if you watched Rick and Morty on Adult
Swim you already know that this is not a
show for kids the science fiction sitcom
follows a mad scientist and his grandson
on their interdimensional adventures and
if you think that the show is too
inappropriate you are not ready to hear
the secrets that they are trying to hide
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know more about the secret
backstory if you love Rick and Morty as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we are showing you ten dark
secrets Rick and Morty tried to hide the
origins did you know that Rick and Morty
was actually based on Back to the Future
you might think that these two shows
have barely anything in common except
for the science fiction but you would be
wrong and the missing piece of the
puzzle is the cartoon the real
adventures of doc and Marty from 2006
the short was a parody of the popular
science fiction movie creator Justin
roiland used it as a protest when he
received cease and desist letters from
his house of Cosby's series as you can
imagine this cartoon was really
inappropriate the characters even had to
be renamed Doc Smith and Marty
McDonald's to avoid a lawsuit but
contrary to popular belief the real
adventures of doc and Marty was not used
as a pilot for Rick and Morty roiland
only used the characters as an initial
speech but he didn't want the producers
to know about the short because it was a
ridiculous unmarketable vandalization of
doc and Marty this is why little
connections remained except for the two
characters time-traveling was also too
complicated for them so they preferred
to work on traveling in space and new
dimensions
moreover the TV series became less and
less inspired by Back to the Future to
avoid any copyright issue but no matter
what their goal remained to pull apart
the tropes of science fiction and this
is how Justin roiland and Dan Harmon
created one of the best sitcoms we have
ever watched the first show Rick and
Morty was not the first show that Dan
Harmon and Justin roiland worked on
together they also produced a
short-lived show that was just weirder
and more inappropriate called mr.
sprinkles the show premiered on vh1 in
2007 unacceptable
and lasted for eight short episodes of
about four minutes long every week
viewers had to vote for their favorite
sketches and mr. sprinkles made it
through each round every time this is
how people had the chance to see one
more episode in the following week but
what made this cartoon successful the
show was a satirical parody of The Cat
in the Hat and once again it was not for
kids mr. sprinkles terrified his young
friends in every episode and the
disturbing undertones were shocking for
most people but no matter what a small
and dedicated audience loved the show
nowadays mr. sprinkles is still the
cartoon that everyone suggests to people
who want to watch something similar to
Rick and Morty you can even see a
reference to the character in the
popular TV series during the second
episode of the second season the white
character with a unique shaped head the
Red Hat and the juggling could be no
announced that mr. sprinkles himself the
show certainly isn't for everyone
but for those who loved Rick and Morty
you will never get enough of mr.
sprinkles the voice actor Rick was drunk
from the first moment we met him and it
never changed it seems like alcohol was
just part of his character which
probably makes him one of the worst role
models and it seems like the crazy
scientists had an influence not only on
kids watching the show but also on
grown-ups working on the project that's
because Justin roiland
the Creator who also voices our favorite
character also drinks alcohol while
recording he posted a video of him doing
shots and getting drunk for a more
inebriated version of Rick for the
episode 4 of season 3 and the craziest
thing is that creator Dan Harmon even
encouraged him saying that things got a
little creative associate producer
Sydney Ryan tried to keep things on
track but it was really hard to do that
with a voice actor under the influence
they concluded that the session was by
far the least productive messiest
recording day they have ever had
we hope that being hungover and knowing
that he did a terrible job will make
Royal and regret drinking all this
alcohol there is never any good reason
to take shots at work and even when you
are partying you should always drink
responsibly we bet that the voice actor
regrets posting this video because you
should have relied more on his skills
than on his bottle of tequila that
lesson to be learned justin roiland the
fourth wall with a crazy shell like Rick
and Morty comes a lot of weird fan
theories one of them is that the mad
scientist's knows that he is part of a
TV show unlike the other characters this
is why he keeps breaking the fourth wall
for example in the first episode Rick
mentioned the website WWE and morty calm
in meeseeks and destroy' and raising
gazorpazorp he also turned to the camera
to say goodbye to the viewers but that's
not the only thing he did in the same
episode Rick also said that the plot
thickens and in Rick's t minutes he made
a reference to how most of the TV shows
were mostly ad-libbed by the creators if
this is not enough to convince you you
have to watch the final episode of the
first season Rick told the audience that
was season 1 thanks for watching it
cannot get any clearer than that the
whole sitcom is about being
disillusioned with your own place in the
universe mostly for the mad scientist
Rick knows that his purpose in this
universe is simply to be there for
entertainment and he seems to accept
this role we have nothing against that
he is great at making us laugh no matter
if this theory is really or not it is
enough to make us smile and that's all
we expect from the awesome show the
female writers in 2016 Adult Swim's
executive vice president Mike lazzo was
accused of not hiring female writers
because when you put women in the
writers room you get conflicts not
comedy on the other channels there is
usually one woman in every five writers
and it seems to work pretty well but on
Adult Swim only 1 in 34 credits was by a
woman in any given series including Rick
and Morty when asked about this Lazo
simply told everyone why he made that
decision instead of saying what he could
do to make things better Dan Harmon was
actually the one who gave a better
reputation to the channel he hired four
more female writers to work on his team
which was the same number of men that
were already working on the project he
called them the joyless ambassadors
against sexism Harmon did the same thing
on his last show community so he knew
that it was going to be a good idea it
was an intimidating task for the new
writers to join a team and get into a
male-dominated genre but they were all
up for the challenge and when we see
there
we know that harmon had a great idea the
third season was just as successful as
the previous one and he also gave women
the chance to be heard that's at least
one thing that we can all learn from
Rick and Morty the shape of the
characters we know that the creators of
Rick and Morty love things that are
inappropriate and when the characters
are not saying something dumb you just
have to look around you to see another
weird thing happening one of them is the
shape of the characters it will take a
little bit of imagination to see this
but you won't forget about it
many aliens are inspired by what you can
see between a man's legs and what is
coming out of it will let you guess what
these things are if you want to see an
example just take a look at the shape of
the head of the Siberians
and the character flim-flam it's hard
not to see it but wait there's more the
characters that evolved in zips
miniver's were inspired by spermatozoids
and most aliens who appeared on the
Rick's must be crazy
we're inspired by many different things
that we cannot say out loud the
sketchbooks of some of the creators are
even filled with phallic looking
character drawings even the Creator said
at a comic-con that they tried sneaking
many phallic designs into the season
they were working on so don't think that
an artist accidentally drew this when
they had something on their mind they
all intended to draw these characters
like that that's just another reason not
to let kids watch this but grown-ups can
still play Where's Waldo by trying to
find these funny aliens the delay once
we start watching Rick and Morty we
can't get enough of it and this is why
many viewers will really disappointed
when the third season took too long to
be released it took almost two years for
us to finally see one more episode of
the sitcom then we understand why most
people were upset fans even started to
worry that Rick and Morty wouldn't be
coming back at all but what took so long
the season 3 premiere debuted on April
Fool's but then there were no more
episodes was the show canceled people
started spreading rumors that Justin
roiland and Dan Harmon had been fighting
and that the show had no chance of
coming back but the creator later
explained that the truth in this case is
so very boring Harmon took the time to
explain everything in a series
of tweets to comfort his fans he says
that the reason season 3 took so long is
that it took long to write because it
was a season 3 of the show and they were
scared to make worse than season 2 or
season 1 it's just a comment yet odd
phenomenon to be a perfectionist and
overthink they were simply doing way
more versions of stuff than needed we
finally got the chance to see the season
3 and we were happier than ever the wait
was worth it after all the intelligence
we all know that Rick is incredibly
smart no matter how much he drinks but
where does his intelligence actually
comes from this is when fan theories
come to the rescue
many people believe that everything was
explained in the first episode the mad
scientist is super smart because of mega
trees and mega seeds we know that they
were important for Rick's research and
we also know that he used them before
and when Morty used the seeds he was
highly intelligent for a moment until
the effect faded and he started drooling
from his mouth does that remind you of
someone
many fans think that Rick is not
actually drinking alcohol but liquid
mega tree seeds but others argue that
this theory doesn't make any sense
if Rick weren't smart without the seeds
he wouldn't be able to travel to another
dimension to find the seeds and drink
them
moreover Rick is the richest Rick which
means that he is in the base dimension
so the mad scientist is just naturally
super-smart fans even think that he is
drinking alcohol to numb the fact that
he is amazing and then it doesn't mean
anything we should just accept the fact
that he is an alcoholic but no matter
what we'll just appreciate the sitcom
like it is you shouldn't ask yourself
too many questions when watching Rick
and Morty the censorship when you want
to create a sitcom with a lot of
inappropriate jokes it comes with a lot
of fans but also a lot of haters this is
why many people tried to censor Rick and
Morty you might think that this show is
for grown-ups
and that adults should have the right to
watch whatever they want but some people
didn't agree with this and the creators
got in trouble they don't mind talking
about sensitive topics drawing alien
heads like a phallus and writing the
most inappropriate jokes but there are
some things that they can't do even
though violence is more and more
accepted they sometimes have to change
this
a little bit for example an alien was
supposed to get his brain blown out but
the creators were asked to change the
color of the brain matter to green
because pink would look too much like a
real brain but what sensors hate the
most is anything that would be too
suggestive for children and we are
talking about the S word the creator's
clearly cross the line when mister jelly
bean tried to do something terrible to
the 14 year old character they had to
handle this scene in a respectful way
and make sure that it didn't sound like
a joke to get the approval of standards
and practices and even though we were
shocked to see that scene in meeseeks
and destroy' we couldn't imagine the
episode without it the secret backstory
did you know that the creators of the
show have been hiding something from us
for all this time there is actually one
secret that they will never reveal
before they wrote the first episode of
Rick and Morty the creators had a
conversation where they said that they
should decide that there is a secret
that they will keep from the audience
forever they will always know it but not
tell anyone about it this is why so many
fans started thinking about crazy
theories and try to find out about the
secret and Dan Harmon even admitted that
someone did guess what the secret was
and made a reddit post where they threw
out the theory he never said which one
was right but many people believe that
reddit user not your parents discovered
the secret plot according to them
Morty passed away during an accident in
the universe where Rick used to live
this is why the mad scientist wanted to
find a way to travel to another universe
and be with his grandson again and now
that Morty is still alive Rick always
takes him on his adventures because he
doesn't want to lose his grandson again
we have to admit that this is our
favorite theory are there any dark
secrets about Rick and Morty that we
forgot don't be shy to tell us what it
is in the comment section down below we
love to hear from you and that's it for
10 dark secrets Rick and Morty tried to
hide for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 Jessi dark secrets
Disney tried to hide thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]